until dawn kind of takes everything
about cliche teenage slasher horror
movies and throws it into one game
for better or worse like i i don't know
if they're trying to
be self-aware about this like you what
we played we were sort of guiding two
characters through this apparently
haunted mansion
and they were the two most annoying
characters i've ever met in any video
game but they're that typical um
super scared but also really stupid
uh horror movie protagonists right well
yeah every single line of dialogue that
came out of their mouths was almost you
know
as expected cliche and cringe-worthy to
that point but at the same time you know
i do want to give it the benefit of
doubt wondering whether or not that was
the whole self-aware like if the game
knows that these characters are so
cliche and they're playing up to their
stereotypes in order to entertain the
person who's playing the game
but that being said you know the the
tropes that are they're all there like
you know you've got the serial killer
who was chasing the two uh teenagers or
young adult and then you've got the the
jump scares as well which the game seems
to have filled plenty uh in in the level
so what did you think about the scare
zone did you actually get any scares i
don't think the scares were really that
scary uh because i was kind of just
fighting with the mechanics the whole
time i mean one of the main things is
you have a torch and you aim the torch
in the world by tilting the ps4
uh controller itself and using the light
bar sensor to direct where the beam is
going and it's so counter-intuitive and
so awkward to be doing these things
while trying to sort of be tense and be
scared
that
it really sort of detracts from the
experience and the level is so bright
that you don't actually need the torch
at all like this isn't as dark as say pt
actually speaking of the motion like
control i feel like that they try to
work that as much into the gameplay as
possible which kind of struck me a
little strange it was very it really
broke the immersion like you said when
you know my character in the cutscene
was speaking about how scared she was
and i was like flipping the controller
back and forth and her head was just
like going everywhere it looked really
strange to me and i'm not even sure what
purpose it served in the game yeah it
looks like every time you try to
interact with an object they have to
bring up the prompt to be like no no
this is how you do it you swipe the
touchpad you move the controller like
this or you do something that you just
like that's not usually how i interact
with things and it really sort of pulls
you out every single time it happens and
as far as i could see when you pick up
an object and rotate it around a lot of
the time it actually didn't achieve
anything like most of the time you could
just tap you know r2 to pick up an
object and after you go there was no
real point in staying there and like
flicking it around and looking at it
exactly like in a game like ellen noir
when you can sort of rotate a single
architect and look at it you're doing it
because you're a detective and you're
trying to find something but when you do
it in until dawn there's only one way
you can actually move the object and you
have to just go all the way and then
release it and then you through to the
next step that being said though i was
pretty impressed with the choices you
had to make throughout the game
sometimes you know the character had to
decide whether or not she was gonna hard
enough and and go for like the scary
choice and chase and look for a missing
friend or say like i'm really scared i
don't want to go in there and i thought
that was really interesting we were
playing next to each other on different
stations though and i noticed we picked
different choices but still ultimately
ended up at the same place at the end
yeah that's true well maybe you know
when the final game is that we'll be
able to see more branching story lines
in until dawn but until then we'll see